[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
let me ask you
Eminem's Mars
oh my God
does the alpha candies are they gonna
leave the dicks on the male M Ms for
Nick Adams I'm just curious if that is
the plan uh
this morning
Eminem seems to be trolling the right
wing and they don't even know they're
being trolled which is very typical in
fashion with them they really don't
understand parody or satire they are
parody and satire of themselves
Decker Carlson Nick Adams and the rest
of them
literally their idea was
there's gonna be another Eminem
with the vagina
so they were gonna cancel M Ms and Mars
in general and now this morning they're
excited that Mars got canceled which
they didn't get canceled No One's Gonna
stop eating M M's you boneheads
they're too good
who in the is actually gonna stop
eating M M's because of one because of
one group of people who claim to be
Alphas in this country are so
butt hurt such snowflakes That
Eminem would create a different colored
cartoon
because it doesn't have a wiener on it
they're really pissed that their M M's
don't have dicks why am I talking about
this again why why oh that's right
Eminem set the trap for him and they
sprung it
I believe this is was a trap the whole
time they say it in a statement
but this is how the right wing works
they create they create something that
is not an issue not a problem no one
gave a about Eminem's genitalia
because they don't have genitalia
now you say this is ridiculous this is
trivial
listen this is their modus operandi this
is how they do this stuff how do you
think how do you think everyone's so
outraged that Joe Biden had documents
how do you think they're doing it how do
you how do you think they do anything
about the laptop about Hillary Clinton's
emails about anything that they talk
about at all gas prices inflation gas
stoves God's abortion
on and on it goes where they manufacture
outrage
this is a prime example
so much so that Mars candy is able to
set a trap for them
and Brilliant marketing Style
brilliant marketing Style
how in the don't they see that
they're being trolled
of course they have a new spokespur
spokeswoman spokesperson Maya Rudolph
wait till they find out she's black oh
it'll really piss him off that
it's got a vagina and it's black that's
the spokesperson I mean literally I I
don't I don't even know how to describe
to you how easily the right wing walked
into this and it's only because their
brains only manufacture
horseshit that's all that's it that's
all they can do is manufacture horseshit
it's not real I I don't know if you've
been noticing on Twitter over the
weekend people posting videos of them
shaking
have you seen this stupid oh my God this
stupid I've been telling you for
over a week now that there's an account
out there on Twitter posting videos that
have no context to the vaccine no
context to covid they're trying to make
some sort of narrative
and somehow the vaccines killing people
now that they can't prove that it's
killing people now they're now they're
getting people to do shaking videos as
if they're having seizures folks I
watched one video of this stupid
ass who claims to be a nurse and
really if she is a nurse she doesn't
need to be one
because she's trying to fake a seizure
and she's talking she's talking during a
seizure listen if you're gonna pretend
to do something why don't you go I don't
know Google the one time
there's another video out there of
someone shaking their legs but the phone
the phone that they're holding to record
their legs shaking because of the
vaccine is is perfectly still
I've never had a seizure I've never
witnessed someone having a seizure in
person I'm it's just something I've
never experienced
but I do know that seizures are
neurological it's your brain not
your body
see your brain you boneheads controls
your nervous system which kind of
controls everything you do the Motions
The Voice the talky talk
right
how in the can a nurse
who is supposed to be some kind of
registered career nurse not no
what a seizure is
and if you don't know you can't go
just just do a little bit of
research if you're gonna fake it
we could tell we know you're faking it
because
you're not you're not it doesn't even
look close that's the one and I'm gonna
show you this video this is this
video is hilarious
it literally looks like she is using a
Shake Weight
you remember the the yeah come
on you know the you know the I'm
not gonna you want me to do the you know
you want me to do the shake weight
motion
that's the Donald Trump YMCA dance
hey he's having one in each hand when he
does the dance she has the one the the
problem is in the video
is she's talking
she's completely Audible
and again she's she's supposedly a nurse
and she doesn't know
that someone who's actually having a
seizure
would more than likely not be able to
form a sentence
let alone enough sounds to form a word
because they're having a neurological
seizure you you people are dumb
you're dumb it's the stupidest
I've ever seen in my life and of
course people are trolling and making
fun of them making their own videos
where they're shaking
because it's so goddamn stupid
it's so goddamn obvious
and it's the delusion though it's the
delusion that they
they correct
you think you you think the
shaking videos and the Eminem thing
aren't the same it's the exact same
thing same same
them being outraged that Eminem's
characters had don't have or have a
certain genitalia or gender is the same
where they're faking shaking videos
because they need to be right about the
vaccine they need they got to be right
about it they have to oh man they have
to be right about the vaccine they're
gonna have to be right about
laptops they got to be right about M M's
they got to be right about the Potato
Head
they got to be right about drag queens
speaking of that
speaking a drank performers
representative George Santos
is caught in an airport as they question
him about being a drag performer he says
oh I was not
drag queen
that was just me young being
fun
having fun having fun dressing up no big
deal I was just dressing up in women's
clothing dancing and performing
just me being young just having fun
they walk into the Trap every single
time of their lives
every single time George Santos is not
special
in Republican lying land folks
he's not
only did he did he lie about what his
name was who he is where he's from what
is what is family
heritage is
he supports a party who supports
stochastic terrorism
to terrorize performers in this country
bleeding all the way down to
children children
they're calling children Bond threats
and children's hospitals
over this stupid
because someone might dress up in a
dress and dance around and perform and
sing and entertain people oh my God
oh so scary oh my God what are we gonna
do oh what would we do if someone
dressed up in a costume and danced
around and entertained people oh my God
it's gonna change the entire structure
of our society all the boys are gonna
want to be girls and all the girls are
Gonna Wanna Be Boys we're gonna they're
gonna chop off our dicks this is stupid
but this is how they think
it's the same as the Eminem thing I know
it you're like oh no it's not yes it is
same
different diaper
George Santos claims that he was not in
drag he claims that he was not a drag
performer he's not drag queen he's just
having fun and being young and
entertaining what the do you think
a goddamn drag performance is
what the you think it is
but they play along Jay will all they'll
play along
just like they play along with this
stupid Eminem thing
of course again Mars is brilliant Eminem
is brilliant I said that the moment this
happened the moment that Tucker Carlson
and Nick Adams at Alpha cuck decided to
take up the mantle and cancel Eminem I
was like oh Eminem knows this is
they
they did this on purpose
they they baited them because they went
on and on and on about sexy boots on
Eminem's for weeks they talked about
what boots and Eminem has on whether
it's sexy or Not Jesus Christ
Eminem was like we're gonna bait these
they're gonna buy it hook
line Sinker and they did it
they did it
and here we are I'm giving a free
30-minute commercial to M M's
you owe me money Mars
[Laughter]
oh my God
you don't think it's the same as
the laptop you might not think it's the
same as their lies about documents
you might think that it's not the same
thing about their lies about the lgbtq
community you may think that it doesn't
have to do with the Second Amendment
Bros
and the Nazis on Twitter but it
has everything to do with it
it just has to do with rather M M's have
dicks or not
they literally are offended that a
cartoon character may or may not
be male or female
they're they're they're snowflakes
I've been telling you this for a long
time that liberalism is not weak
liberals in this country and we need to
stop being so goddamn scared of that
word liberal I'm a liberal
liberal is for freedom for liberty for
choice for democracy
how the do you want to run away
from that word liberal
Liberals are not weak
democracy is tough
Freedom's tough
Liberty is really tough I don't
know if you if you've known the history
of our country but Liberty is a is a bad
to get
especially when you have a bunch a
stupid white ball sacks trying
to stifle everyone else's
Liberty
because the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
it's not
and it's difficult for democracy
you have to be strong you have to stay
strong
you have to continue day after day after
day looking for progress in the future
because you're not going to get
everything you want
in a democracy especially a liberal
democracy you're not you're not going to
get everything you individually want
but we must strive
for Liberty
and the way we do that is through our
freedoms and our rights
and our constitution gives us that
ability
but the right wing always wants to put
up a blockade in this country
always
wants to put up a blockade and tell you
why
you're not allowed to have Liberty
why you're not
why you can't eat M M's because they
don't have wieners on them
why you can't watch this football game
because this person's woke why you can't
go to Disney World
because they support their lgbtq
Community they don't hate
Florida where wokism
goes to die
I have a feeling that the fascist and
then Ron DeSantis Nazis
are gonna eat those words I have
confidence in you
the American people the voters
hell people who don't vote yet
I have confidence in you
most people believe it or not in this
country rather they want to identify or
not or they like the word or not are
liberal
I'm a moderate
oh my daddy was a republican but I'm a
moderate Republican I'm an independent
you're liberal you just don't
know it
and the reason why is because we
liberals
who know what we are
think it's a scary word it's not a scary
word
it's not scary to self-identify as a
liberal
politically socially
it means freedom
it
literally go look up the word
liberal small L I'm not talking about
Big L I'm talking about small L liberal
the Western world is a liberal democracy
why do you think they want to smash up
our democracy
because liberalism is their enemy
freedom is not their friend
authoritarians don't want their
population to have freedom
they don't want it they don't want you
to be free to eat whatever
Eminem has whatever genitalia that you
want they want to tell you you only
gotta eat the ones with dicks on them
why do you think they're so upset
I know it seems weird and
hilarious that it's all with this Eminem
thing but folks this is a prime example
it's a prime example of their
mindset and their world view on
everything women's rights gun reform
Health Care decent Affordable
Health Care not going broke because you
because you get a medical bill
the idea that you would educate someone
on the truth in Real History
and start those at that education and as
soon as you possibly can when that child
is three
and educate them all the way up into
their 20s and pay for it it's a good
investment they don't like investments
into society they don't want you to have
a leg up
authoritarians don't want you to have a
leg up they only want the people that
they choose to have a leg up
so if this sounds like you you don't
want that authoritarian
particularly this
this trolling that Eminem's is doing of
the right wing which is uh it's
brilliant there's such parodies of
themselves they don't even know when
it's happening to them it's
beautiful it's hilarious
consider yourself a liberal
and say it proud be proud of it
that you're for democracy that you're
pro-democracy
that you want to have Choice yeah it's
not perfect
democracies aren't I mean look at
Ukraine at this point Ukraine is not
The Shining City on the hill as far as
democracies go a lot of corruption
they're not perfect not even close but
it's still worth fighting for it's worth
dying for
to make sure that authoritarian rule
does not take over their Sovereign
Nation
that's how important just that simple
little prominent idea is of liberalism
that word is power that word is strength
not weakness
you want to see weakness go look at
Tucker Carlson on Fox news about
how Eminem's change the color and it's
got a giner not a wiener
and they're gonna go buy go buy M M's
and then smash them on videos on the
internet
foreign
get the out of here with that
nonsense it's like when they were
burning jerseys because Colin Kaepernick
took a knee to make sure that the world
knew he was protesting that police
officers were murdering black people
and they were offended
so much so that the guy still isn't
throwing the football
because they got butt hurt
their feelings were hurt
because he was pointing out that police
officers murdered black people how dare
he tell the truth how dare Eminem how
dare they
draw a cartoon character that doesn't
identify as me
how dare they do it in someone else's
image how dare they how dare they give
an opportunity to someone else being I'd
be identified in a cartoon character how
dare they
that's that's weak
that's fascist
that's authoritarian
who gives a flying what Eminem
draws their character says who gives a
flying rat's ass
they taste the same rather they draw the
cartoons one way or the other it's
marketing dummies they're just trying to
sell you candy they don't give a
about anything but one color and one
thing only and one gender it's money
profit baby that's their that's
their
that's their pronoun prophet dummies
the out of here with this nonsense
but that's what they do at every step at
every measure
and that's why we have to stay vigilant
that's why we cannot let these
idiots take over our governments they're
a joke
they're creating a manufactured crisis
in this country over the gender
of M MS
literally people are upset on the
internet they're they're also making
fake ass videos where they're shaking
because they can't be wrong about a
vaccine and about coronavirus in
general
they were wrong in general almost on
every single point they're wrong
and they're pissed that they're wrong
I'm going to show you video today
speaking of covid
and vaccines and people not getting them
or people getting them and faking
the shakes or seizures whatever the hell
they're doing
Donald Trump went to um I think her
name's Diamond she died because she
didn't get a vaccine while she was
pushing vaccine conspiracy theories so
good her
he goes to her funeral and talks about
himself
or or that Joe Biden stole the election
from him what that has to do with her I
have no idea it's hilarious because he
was he had to sit there for three
hours he even says out loud that
I thought this was only going to be 15
minutes I thought I was gonna come up
here you guys are going to cheer me on I
was gonna be the headliner and then I
was gonna leave no they made him sit
there for three hours
oh God damn
he's he's he's he is getting more
irrelevant every single minute I
can't even believe that he's actually
gonna be their nominee he's going to be
their nominee I know you're saying
you're crazy Tony you're crazy
there's no way I'm telling you he's
going to be their nominee and he's going
to be so irrelevant in American society
by the time we get there because of all
the crazy that he's gonna do and
say and position himself against
American values as if he hasn't done
that already
this documents cases already oh it's a
beauty oh it's a beaut
trust me on this this is not going to go
well for Trump on this document's case
the Biden part the media is freaking out
about oh my God oh my God they allowed
they allowed voluntarily for the
Department of Justice to come do their
own search of his home
yeah okay
so is it bad that the Department of
Justice goes and reads a home or is it
good which is it which is it that our
government gets back the documents that
we supposed to have is that good or is
that bad
because if it's good in the if it's good
that the Department of Justice and the
government make sure to get back
documents that are ours rather they were
inadvertently they are not
or they were stolen to cover up a coup
attempt if if it is good that the
government gets back those documents
then how is it not bad in Trump's case
that he's obstructing them getting them
back and he's hiding them and destroying
them what happened what happened to the
empty folder documents in the empty
folders huh you stick where are
they what'd you do with them what did
you bury them in a casket did you sell
them to Saudi Arabia is that what you
did because we're not getting any sense
that Joe Biden has empty
classified folders at this point
he's not eaten burning or
selling secrets to Saudi Arabia or
burying them in a casket on the
back nine okay okay to cover up a
coup attempt to cover up his
goddamn collusion with Russia to cover
up the P tape that's right I said it
he's stealing documents to cover
up the P tape too
doubt me just doubt me uh 10
years from now we'll know we will know
that Tony is correct just like he always
is yes he stole the documents to cover
up his obstruction with with the
with James Comey with the
collusion and Michael Flynn
he stole the documents to cover
up the goddamn p-tape and his
coup attempt on January 6th and he
destroyed documents
and he sold documents I'm sure of it
he's a scumbag he's the lowest
scumbag that we've ever had anywhere
near the presidency or the presidency in
our country's history and it's not gonna
go anywhere it's gonna stay that way
so yeah I'm very confident I'm very
confident that the scummiest of the
scummies is Trump and he did the
scummiest with those documents
and what you're going to find with the
special counsel
with Joe Biden is they're going to be
like well that went over like a wet fart
and a white thong no criminal activity
there oh by the way you
right-wing Eminem candy love and
bastards
I wonder how many laptops they found in
the search at Joe Biden's home everyone
you're here it's Monday as you here are
here every single Monday and every
single weekday I am to noon Eastern 11
Central nines Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and twitch for two full hours also
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page don't forget to subscribe
to the YouTube channel right now hit
that sub button we're trying to get to
20 000 two years of Tony also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
and Google and if you're on Facebook
right now follow me at the Tony Michaels
if you're on the Midas touch Facebook
page follow me at the Tony Michaels
follow our page too why the not
doesn't cost anything to subscribe to
YouTube follow us on Twitter to download
every single episode it doesn't cost
anything
to follow us on Facebook it doesn't cost
anything to download the Twitch app and
watch us from Twitter twitch every once
in a while a lot of people like the chat
over there twitch is a little different
than YouTube so download the Twitch app
watch us on Twitch it doesn't cost you a
thing doesn't cost you a thing I am
super excited about this week
and the news that we're going to have
we're also going to talk today about the
shooting
um in Monterey Park
because we just can't get over this gun
so everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the word that
I'm struggling with I chose Babel mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
your ability
good massive amounts of people
violates our rights and our Liberty in
this country it truly does so what it
does is it violates our rights our
rights in this country
boy oh boy
what a sad situation
um at a uh
Monterey Park out in Los Angeles at a
chinese-american uh Lunar New Year
celebration
someone kills 10 I believe is the number
now and uh injures 10 more
um I might have my numbers wrong
[Music]
um
we are so numb to this situation in our
country and I'm not talking about this
one event because it's not just one
event
it's domestic violence events all around
the country where people are
being slaughtered in domestic violence
events because we can't
get our heads wrapped around that it's
the guns
we have people being mowed down in
churches and parades
and nightclubs
grocery stores
it's pathetic
it's pathetic that we absolutely think
that we can't do anything about it
that we are a society that can't look at
each other
and make good decisions
based on
weapons of war
it's pathetic
school children being slaughtered in
schools
you can't even go to a school safely
it's the guns
you boneheads and not only is it the
guns it's the culture around it right
they're gonna blame it on mental health
or whatever because I guess um the
gunman was found uh with a
self-inflicted gunshot wound in a
vehicle
you're gonna blame it on mental illness
well mentally ill all not all mentally
old people go and try to slaughter
dozens of people folks
even even mentally ill people who do
have guns who are responsible gun owners
don't go Slaughter dozens of people
it's not the I mean we need mental
health care in this country don't get me
wrong we need it and we need it fast I
don't know if you've seen these dilute
diluted right-wing moglodytes
but we need some we need some Mental
Health Care fast I mean quick and in a
hurry
but not all people who have suffer from
a mental illness want to do a
mass murder
it's the culture it's the gun culture
that is making someone cross the Rubicon
not only do they have access to weapons
of war they may they may just may have a
mental illness
but the culture has embedded the idea
that the only way to fix your problem
the only way to fix your problem in this
country
when you have one it's a gun
most ridiculous thing I've ever seen in
my my life and I when I was a kid
there wasn't this idea that you could
solve problems with guns it first
started it first started there oh yeah
80s 90s
they saw it coming that's why they
passed the assault weapons ban it worked
it worked because they realized
our culture was going down the wrong
path
and to give people in this country
because they weren't going to give us
Mental Health Care no they weren't
going to give us Health Care mineral
Healthcare that
but they saw where the gun culture was
going they saw where the technology of
weapons were going on the streets
and they decided then and hey maybe we
shouldn't be pairing all these things
together right
if we're not if we're not going to
provide as a government the proper
structure of society to make sure people
get proper treatment when they need it
maybe we should just limit the access to
the have the deadly weapons of
war maybe we should do that so they're
not just murdering people and
then Republicans are like we don't like
that
there's not enough money in that
we want people to be murdering people
there's a lot of money in that
doubt me Wayne lapair Wayne lap pair
spokesperson for the NRA went to
Congress
after the shooting in Colorado
where children were murdered
by two P two two teenagers with guns in
a high school
and he pushed for gun reform
but the gun manufacturers learn really
fast and really quick
that mass shootings didn't have the
effect on profits that they thought they
would they thought they would lose
profit
with the mass shooting
the fact of the matter is is that
profits went up baby
now they went up oh yeah you you you get
a you get a good gun not to threaten
that the government's gonna take your
guns boy these other gun nuts
will buy more of them it's a hell of a
pro it's a hell of a profit model
hell the prophet model you have a big
huge mass shooting a bunch of elementary
students get killed
you give your thoughts and prayers and
then you say take it out of my cold dead
hands they they're just using this as a
false flag to take your guns they're
gonna take your remember
Obama's gonna take your guns for eight
years didn't
Biden's been gonna take your guns for
two years now and
it's all manufactured it's the m m thing
folks it's the I
it's crazy it's the Eminem thing
same different diaper
manufactured crisis that the
government's gonna come take your guns
Second Amendment rights we need
to be able to overtake the government
I need to defend me some from some
enemies
what kind of enemies do you got
that your children have to stand around
a Christmas tree Thomas Massey and
Lauren bobert with with
semi-automatic weapons what kind of
enemies do you got we played a
video last week of a dad training his
what appeared to be a three-year-old a
toddler
how to kill human beings
with a handgun
he wasn't training him to shoot a deer
he wouldn't train him to shoot a turkey
he wasn't training him for target
practice he was training him to kill
humans he is training a mass shooter
because that's the culture you got a
problem son you got a problem are they
trying to take away your whiteness are
they trying to take away your white
privilege are they trying to give rights
to lgbtq people well you must defend
yourself from the tyrannical government
that is trying to give people Liberty
that's the culture
doubt me I I know the
culture I've been around it I've seen it
they used to talk about gun safety when
it comes to hunting
as a kid you went to gun safety courses
before you do the use shooting
a deer season in Missouri they had a
youth hunt
and you would go to the conservation
department the Missouri con the
government
foreign
classes on gun safety
that's how the NRA got out of
their old racist ways
and walked away from the KKK as they
rebranded themselves as a gun and
hunting safety organization
they're not talking about hunting deer
and turkey anymore folks they're talking
about hunting politicians
hunting humans
rhinos remember Eric greitens the former
Governor that lunatic
making a video in the primary that he
was gonna gun down rhinos gun down
people of his own body
if they didn't do what the he said
and what the Trump said and what
the the Nazis say seems fascist to
me
but that's the culture
they turn this stupid gun
culture into white authoritarian
Christian nationalism pew pew we own
guns and we're going to kill anyone that
we don't like because when you got a
problem when you got a problem in your
white in this country a gun will solve
it oh you can't get black people guns
and people of color they don't get guns
they don't solve problems that's they're
Thugs and criminals when they have guns
when white people have guns they're
they're solving problems they're
protecting them and their family you
know from them other people
that's the culture
and it bleeds everywhere
including in grocery stores and on
school classroom School floors
in the pews and churches
it bleeds in Office Buildings it bleeds
in nightclubs it bleeds in restaurants
it bleeds and homes
it's a disease that we have
it's not because of mental illness you
idiots
there's a lot of people in this country
that have mental illness a lot
almost every single one of us Hem of
Mental Illness but it doesn't drive
every single one of us to murder
people with the goddamn weapon of War
so do we need male to Health Care you
God damn right we do
and we shouldn't go broke to get mental
health care
we also
we also should recognize that it's the
gun
Gabe Sanchez is going to give us a good
idea on some of the details out in
Monterey Park
but it's the it's the gun
you we could go through every single
detail how many people kill when it
happened who did it what the gun was
where they bought it what ammunition
they use what the exact gun is
how long they've owned it rather there
was a straw purchaser whatever the
they want to say about it it's the
gun
it's the guns
I know Gabe Sanchez agrees with me on
this point
Gabe um you're pretty close out there me
uh in L.A I don't know if the mood is um
what the mood's like out there over the
weekend because this happened
um can you give us some new updates and
details on the Monterey Park uh shooting
of course yeah I said it you know all
the details don't really in in reality
matter only to the victims and their
families because they've lost loved ones
again because we can't get it through
our thick skulls that we have to do
something about the guns now apparently
this weapon was illegally purchased or
it's illegal to own it in California
um and the shooter died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound but what do
we know is there any updates on how many
people are actually were
murdered now uh over yeah obsession with
gun culture and guns so the the number
that we currently have is that there
were 10 people that were killed and
there were 10 people that were injured
so we haven't gotten any more fatalities
yeah yeah they've identified the only
the updates that are coming out right
now is the identification of people that
have been killed right because they have
notified the families at this point
exactly
um and yeah so like the
if we go the mood out here
um
you know because I don't live I live
like I don't know my handful five five
it's like two neighborhoods over
essentially
uh from from Monterey Park yeah from
where I live I'm on the east side of L.A
uh and that's also on the east side of
the way so so it's not far away yeah
have you ever seen or uh because this
was a festival type um setting yeah it
was it was a lunar Lunar New Year
Festival it was at a ballroom there's
it's a dance venue
um it's so it's kind of a big a big
building where weddings and yeah yeah
birthday parties and like dance
Hill right right and from what from what
I hear uh because I've never been there
myself but what I was reading is
typically packed there's always people
there it's a community area there's
always somebody showing up to to go you
know do the fox Trotter go do this dance
or whatever it might be
um
so that the only the only developments
that we have is outside of uh you know
identifying new people or identifying
people that they haven't already but
then also understanding you know how
this played out so you said
self-inflicted gun wound you know the
Assumption of course is that when he was
surrounded uh you know because there are
photos online where you see three SWAT
armored trucks like they pinned them in
um and the self-infliction obviously is
like the Assumption there is he killed
himself right and this guy's was 72
years old and from what I understand and
again like you know when when you when
people talk about this stuff you're like
oh is this a hate crime is it not a hate
crime
you know there are people leaders in the
community yesterday that came out and
they're like we don't believe this to be
a hate crime
um that's not to say that someone within
their own Community can attack someone
else from their own Community right like
you can have white supremacy within your
own
um uh Democrat within your own
background racial background um whatever
it might be you can still have that so
that isn't totally outside the realm of
possibility the motive right now is
still TBD right they still don't know
they're still trying to understand it
but some early speculation is that this
is all just a domestic dispute right so
the wife of this of this shooter this
killer was invited to this party this
event he wasn't invited from what I've
been Gathering and from there
people have also said that this guy has
always been a little bit off some people
have been speculating you know whether
it was time in Vietnam during
uh during war like there's all these
things up there we don't know yet
but right now it looks like it's a at
least right now and it could change it
looked like a domestic kind of uh
yeah yeah she you know she was invited
he was and she went he didn't and then
he came out and then took it on a bunch
of people again that could very well
change we don't know the motive is still
out in the unknown
but the things that we have learned uh
more about is like the 26 year old who
helped to take down
um
the shooter and remove the gun right
um this this this kid
um wrestled an assault pistol from the
shooter's hands and you know obviously
prevented a greater tragedy
so we're gonna find out more probably as
the days come on you know because we've
we've got a 72 year old man who shows up
with a gun shoots people that are there
having you know trying to have a good
time celebrate the Lunar New Year and be
with our community and we don't quite
know the exact motive for why he was
doing it and why he was targeting
everyone
but we do we are beginning to learn more
about the people that were involved in
you know disarming him and and getting
the gun away from him and saving those
the other countless people right uh and
then after that happened you know there
were notices that came out to say like
look for this guy which was very unsus
like you look at this guy and you're
like wait this guy's a shooter and that
reminds you that anyone can be a
shooter but it really does come back
they are people they are I mean they are
it's not our people Shooters are not
always just white in cells right it's
not always this guy who's been sitting
in the basement all triggered by
the forums or whatever it could be
anyone right and it could be people
within their own Community attacking
other people in their own community
but the other thing that is really
important is what you were talking
before it's the gun right the
accessibility to guns is way way too
easy right it seems like no matter the
race or the person's background or their
mental health status it always seems to
be there's one thing that is always in
common with a mass shooting it's almost
like there's one thing that makes it a
mass shooting and a mass killing no
matter the age uh the gender of the
person the race of the person the
religion why they're doing it what their
motor it almost seems like Gabe Sanchez
right there's one thing tying them all
together it's almost like there's
something that they're using that we
allow them to use in our society that
we're allowing them to have access to to
do these things it's almost like there's
and also like the idea that you know
because people like oh I want to be
putting on a registry list and I don't
have to it's like okay there are reasons
why we require or or at least we want to
make sure hey do you have the proper
training like I was I was having a
dinner last night every single one of
these has a social
security number they got a driver's
license
they are stupid you know for the same
reason you know not saying that this is
the guy but for the same reason I'd say
oh I need my guns to defend myself
against a a tyrannical government it's
like again they've got predator
drones they've got
uh
Bazookas they've got a tank that
could roll into your house and not even
give two shits about what's going on
with you stealth bombers I mean
you right they really are barking around
if they really wanted to take you out if
the government really said hey John Doe
I don't like you they could take
the craziest part about it never know
the craziest part about it is that most
these people claim to be Patriots and
they love the vets and they support
veterans and they love the military and
they don't know that that the people
that's their enemy in the war against
the government right
like you're a patriot but you're gonna
kill members of the military because you
know that's probably
um thinking about it here that's why
they don't really put Humanity
um in this equation right this gun
culture doesn't really account for
Humanity because they're like oh the
government you know they're robots you
know like no the military is
people their sons their daughters they
have children they're wives their
husbands right these are people
these are human beings but they
they just they sanitize and dehumanize
every thing they possibly can
for their reality to be real I mean even
and again I know this sounds crazy
but the gun culture thing and how
they're 2A and they only give a
about one well two amendments right now
three they love the Fifth Amendment
because their Heroes have to
take the Fifth Amendment every time they
get in front of a goddamn uh uh uh
subpoena or or a deposition but the
point is this they only know about a
couple amendments in the first place and
their sacred god-given amendments right
but
when it comes down to it when it comes
down to it they absolutely are not
Patriots they are not for military
veterans they are not for the military
they are only for their false narrative
to be correct no matter what no matter
what the stakes we watched this over the
weekend I know this sounds stupid that
this is tied to the gun culture but it's
the same people folks it's the
same people pushing the gun narrative
the gun culture that it is people making
the shaking videos online as if the
vaccine is making them have these shakes
and it's obviously it looks they I mean
honestly it looks like those people are
having orgasms uh but well I'm
gonna show one video later it looks like
she's using she has Superior Shake
Weight form oh I mean Superior
infomercial stats but the other thing I
do want to add is you know Republicans
want to talk about oh it's mental health
and this and that right well you know
where a lot of suicides happen with guns
where's that add gun ranges oh no people
having more people more guns creates
more more dead humans and the thing is
like Republicans don't want to talk
about that right other people are you
know trying to pass bills or trying to
pass laws but obviously that's going
against your second name a ride God
forbid you have me do a whole training
seminar or have me verify who I am when
I get my gun so I can kill myself that
is what they don't want they don't want
people because they don't talk about
that stuff and that's something that
really does happen like here in La
there's a gun range downtown and there
are some people that are like yeah I
would never go there because people have
killed themselves there because they
easily get themselves there's no
training you just show up with a
license you're like yep I am this person
here's my license and I go good enough
for me and they give you the gun
and they give you some bullets and you
go to the gun range and like pew pew
right just that's what it is
and Republicans don't want to talk about
that
and as much as they want to you know
push the idea oh it's you know
if the person because here's here's how
it goes right there's like a
decision tree is the shooter white yes
no yes oh it's mental health no oh you
know what they're just an illegal person
from another country trying to take it
out on Americans it really just goes
through that cycle right and they're
like oh well oh they're white okay well
this and then okay well let's fight
about you know Mental Health
but at the end of the day they don't
really care about that they'll try it
out quote unquote push bills that
support mental health there was a bill
last year where they were like uh do we
really want to do that I don't think so
guys we can talk a big game but we're
not going to walk a big game here so you
guys can go yourselves and we'll
barely support it and anything else
that's beyond that especially if you're
like hey look again we're not coming for
your guns it's simply just saying hey if
you have a firearm just like your car or
just like something else we ask that you
register it so that's just like not out
there and just doing because if
that car killed someone God forbid and
you're like hey who is the car
registered to right oh there's a broken
you know tail light we can match the the
the glass or the plastic to the light to
the make and model of the car to the
owner of the car to figure out who
killed this person no Republicans don't
want that they don't want to have the
serial number on there they don't have
the bullets that go to the gun they
don't want the person's name attached to
the gun games the Republican party I
think I I found
a compromise okay for regulation in this
country
I think I found it I think I found the
answer
because these people are are absolutely
they believe that the left is absolutely
obsessed with sex and and their their
sex demons
here's my proposal here's my proposal is
that if we give up
our our sex toys and regulate and
register our sex toys the left because
we know that it's only the left it's
only liberals and socialists and
progressives in this country that would
ever participate in anything like sex
toys or you know this degenerate sex
culture if we do that if we let them
regulate and register our sex toys then
maybe just maybe they will let us
regulate
and register their firearms I'm just
saying it's a pretty good tree
I would totally let them register my
strap on yeah if absolutely 100 if I
need even if I got to take a class to
know how to use it properly you know how
to clean it properly I would do that I
mean absolutely when I when I got a sex
toy I read the manual what are
the settings on this thing right what
does it do I mean you know you don't
want to go and into a sex machine
situation and and have that sumbitch on
high immediately I mean there's certain
it's like you can burn yourself exactly
exactly there's a safe way to use a sex
machine and an unstable you know it's
joking but they are parodies of
themselves right so maybe they would buy
into this like you know a lot of people
are pissed off about this Eminem thing
and I know I keep tying the Eminem thing
it's the left and the right which is
hilarious oh my God hilarious what's
what's funny is is when I sent this to
you this morning I was like oh they're
true and you're like they're trolling
right I'm like oh yeah oh I've seen it
immediately as trolling there's no way
there's no way because here's the thing
there's no way they would yeah I mean if
you're gonna show it on this one well
let's let's do this let's because we got
we got plenty of stuff to look at today
on the list round yeah yeah so
let's surf the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends start countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the show you have
reached the part of the Tony Michaels
podcast where we ran up at the Tweet
tweets and training trends the shitless
Roundup and we speaking of
Tucker Carlson Nick Adams they wanted to
cancel Eminem
for the that that this is the the second
time or third time or who no I
don't know it's all sexual
Anarchy toning sexual Anarchy they're
offended by sexy boots non-sexy boots
they're sex they're offended if uh
Eminem has genitalia which that is new
to me I did not know Eminem's had
genitalia but Nick Adams is absolutely
obsessed with Eminem penises
um we know the Saga here we've covered
it here on the show last year
um it was Tucker Carlson I got freaked
out over the green Eminem not having
sexy boots it just wasn't sexy enough he
couldn't jerk off to the green Eminem
anymore he got really pissed so that was
the they wanted to cancel Eminem at that
point now password
all the way to I don't know whenever
it's about three months ago when Eminem
came out with this new uh spokes cartoon
character yeah I think it's called Uh
spokes candy spokes candy yeah whatever
yeah whatever okay that's okay
um so it's purple and they're mad that
it's it's got eyelashes and looks like a
girl and identifies as uh uh her you
know they're always pissed off about
pronouns they gotta be pissed off about
well there's a there's a lot there's a
lot of stuff right there was the idea
that it was a shiny psyop
well it's a q Anon World we're just
living in it yeah but Nick Adams uh goes
to New York apparently I don't know if
he was there to go see uh George Santos
dance around and his uh his he was he
was 10 fun not drag it's not a dragon
it's not Drake costumes it's just it's
just just all in fun he's young right
he's young he's having fun not exactly
Jack so I don't know if he went up there
to watch uh uh George Santos give him a
private performance or not but he
stopped by the Eminem store the Mars
store their Times Square he purchased a
package which Gabe Sanchez found this
Audi purchased a package of him and in
someplace else because the package M M's
had in the video
is not available at the m m store right
so he buys M M's he supports Eminem in
their profit by buying a package not
only that but he supports whatever the
business he bought it from right and
then you know right which they're going
to sell more M M's because he bought M
M's so there's a there's a demand so
they're going to keep selling right
anyways capitalism is a and he
also told all of his followers go buy
the biggest bag
and then smash him on the ground and
take a photo yeah so um Nick Adams
decides he doesn't like M M's unless
they have dicks on them he literally
said the oh he's demanding that their
only M M's with wieners because he wants
the wiener Eminem's to melt in his mouth
not in his hand
um and then Tucker Carlson goes on a
tirade on Fox news about this purple
Eminem and here we are this is the
statement from Eminem now I Gabe I see
this the same way you see this this is a
troll they're trolling them there's this
is not this is not a serious statement
um this is satire this is parody the
only reason why this seems like an a
weird timeline that we're in is because
these people are parody and satire of
themselves and I believe
I believe after the green m m debacle I
almost I almost bet you money
that Eminem after Tucker Carlson went on
a tirade about the the green m m not
being as sexy as he needed it to be to
get off when he's jerking it is that
Eminem and everyone freaked out and
laughed at him and mocked him because
it's stupid what a dumb thing to be
upset about because they manufacture
these things to be upset about
that Eminem sales went up I almost
guarantee you that Eminem sales went up
so like Hey we're gonna come out with
this new character how can we trick the
right wing into canceling us again like
I I almost bet that was part of the
conversation in the marketing scheme but
there's only one there's only one thing
that marketing is intended for and that
is profit that is it it's just for
profit there's nothing more there's no
other alternative motive and if they can
use whatever PR they can get for their
marketing especially if they plan it out
correctly
ex then they're going to do it for
profit but here's the statement from
Eminem let me let me read part of this
and then we'll discuss it as we go along
because I believe there's parody and
satire built into this whole this whole
statement oh yeah America
just the first word
first word like literally M M's are sold
all over the world yeah all over the
world these candy spokespersons are all
over the world but there's no outrage
anywhere else other than here because of
a bunch of right-wing Alpha
trolls so they start by saying America
which again is parody and stats are what
rock because because also remember
within the last years they're going to
talk about so one year ago is it almost
like three days to the day is when
Tucker went on this full-on rant about
the green m m being sexy and the no high
heel boots right so they go on to say in
the last year we've made some changes to
our beloved spokes candies which is
their right they own the
trademarks it's their cartoons it's
called marketing they use the cartoons
Tucker and Nick as marketing it's
marketing it has nothing to do with
wieners our vaginas or any it's just
marketing dude
okay they said we weren't sure if anyone
would even notice that means they did
know Tucker Carlson in the right would
notice folks that's exactly what they're
saying there I expect them to talk about
it tonight
and we definitely didn't think it would
break the internet you absolutely knew
that if Tucker Carlson would go on a
tirade about a purple m m with a vagina
that you that it would break the
internet you've experienced this just a
year ago you just said that they're
totally making comedy here but now we
get it
now we get it oh my God this is great I
can't even believe someone on the left
sees this and reads this out loud or
even to themselves and doesn't
understand that they're trolling the
out of them oh yeah uh now we get
it even a candy shoes can be polarized
yeah how the is someone reading
this and think Eminem isn't trolling
them I don't as soon as as soon as you
as as soon as you get to but now we get
it they're like oh this whole time we've
been totally right ignorant no
idea the shoes were polarizing on a
cartoon oh my God
should I go on to say which which was
the last thing Eminem's wanted since
we're all about bringing people together
I go on to say therefore we have decided
to take an indefinite pause from the
spokes candies
in their place we will Pratt we are
proud to introduce a spokesperson
America can agree on
the Beloved Maya Randolph Rudolph excuse
me we are confident Miss Rudolph Will
Champion
the power of fun to create a world where
everyone feels they belong Gabe Sanchez
can you tell me why this spokesperson is
truly a dig at the right wing and why
why they are probably going to be more
pissed off that they are making her the
spokesperson in true fashion to troll
them yeah to take away the cartoons that
they're offended about and give them a
real person to be offended about tell me
why that yeah yeah it's pretty it's
pretty easy so
not only is Maya Rudolph a woman right
wait wait wait wait wait she has the
that's the wrong genitalia for Nick
Adams and Eminem's I'm just saying no
I'm saying that has to be a man because
they just went they just went off and
they said this is feminist this is
feministic it take on me you know
whatever okay this is good anyway oh
this is gonna be trouble but not only is
she a woman
not only is she a woman
but she's a non-white woman oh my God so
now
Republicans are at an interesting
Crossroads let's say please please do
not tell me
that she is a supporter of equality and
equity and the LGBT she is
oh my God no they had they needed to
make a white alpha male that the
spokesperson
they should have got Kid Rock as the
spokesperson for M Ms this is why
they're going to be mad and and folks if
you're out there and you're mad at M M's
they got you two they got you it's like
when Gabe makes a fake message from
Trump and he tricks you and you're mad
Seth averson then he tricked you and
then you make up some excuse about why
you're mad that it's not comedy no they
got you Eminem is trolling got him Eman
it is this is I I can't even
love
I can hear the recordings of the
boardroom marketing meetings of these
people sitting around going oh we're
totally gonna bait Tucker Carlson here
oh we're gonna get this to
talk about this here's what we're gonna
do when they mention it we will pull
back we will pull the characters back
intentionally take him away from the
American people and give them awoke
spoke awoke just a picture awoke spokes
if you're not socialism was the
number one thread to America according
to Republicans oh like you better think
again it's woke spokes candy Eminem is
gonna have I mean just hours of free
commercials all over right wing talk
absolute free
commercials everywhere and people
because because honestly I mean I really
like Eminem's I particularly like the
peanut butter and the peanut Eminem
they're they're my I would say really
good they're like my top three
candy they're really I actually
don't even like eating them because I
have to finish the whole bag
honestly I I you just it's almost like a
Snickers the same way if you buy it
you're not gonna eat half of it you're
just not gonna eat half the bag of M M's
there's no way and no matter how
big the bag is and you buy one of them
gallon size bags of the peanut M
Ms your ass is gonna go till you're sick
or that bag's done right that's the
problem with Eminem's is they're so
delicious and when when you have
something like candy particularly M MS
and someone starts talking about you
have triggers you have triggers you
taste it you feel it you want it you
start to desire it and there
what they're gonna do is go on tirades
for the next three weeks about M
Ms and it is going to Skyrocket mark my
words it is going to Skyrocket the sales
of Eminem's and they're gonna have more
profit Mars is going to have more profit
off that product of M M's that line of
products of M M's than they've had since
last year when Tucker Carlson decided
that the green m m needs to be sexier so
he can jerk off to her but the other the
other thing too that people need to
understand is this is all like what do
here what do we have happening a big
American event that's happening next
month Tony no huh what what could it be
is it the sports ball thing oh it's the
super sports ball thing oh this the
super of the super sports yeah is there
going to be a commercial there's there's
really famous commercials
here do you remember it was La 2020 they
killed Mr Peanut do you remember that
I don't well yeah their whole campaign
how they killed Mr Peanut that was like
back in 2020 right now okay I'm so
mad about that again it's
not a real thing dude they're not real
it's their cartoons
so what's gonna happen Superman died too
by the way Superman died too what just
yeah he died he died I mean he came back
alive okay okay okay because it's fake
it's not right oh right make believe
right classic but what people need to
realize is that what's Happening Here is
they they played them right they saw how
they reacted in the great I'm assuming
if I had to guess the green m m change
they're like we're gonna change it right
uh we don't we don't know if people are
gonna respond to it whatever they made
they probably didn't they probably
didn't even think about it that way they
were just changing we're gonna change it
we're gonna change it and then a year
later because again this is like well I
guess less than a year later in October
they made the change right
and which they may have been planning it
for a while the plans may have changed
when they saw how right the
right wing reacted to them changing the
shoes right the shoes on a cartoon
character that's on there go go back to
the uh the announcement
yeah okay here hang on let's let's see
because there's something I want people
to realize there's a detail here of what
they did so one not only I feel like
that orange okay by the way that orange
Eminem is very much uh Tucker
Carlson oh God like it's freaking out
okay they gave him his own Eminem I
think I think that's done that's the
right wing that is the right wing
they're scared of woke is him he's like
what they did here
is they talked about these M M's like oh
we didn't know that M Ms were gonna be
so polarizing right for sure we didn't
know that they would freak out yeah a
good other than reading it and reading
it through again
the fact that they included the m m
characters at the bottom is definitely
one like your first flag to be like oh
that's weird why would they say this but
then also include the imagery number two
not only do they include the M Ms they
included the new purple Eminem right
right and then not only did they include
that one they included the the new gym
shoes on the green m m which were
changed temporarily
in marketing to back to the high heels
right so if you go back to Fox News
they're like well I guess because Tucker
was like well I guess she's an obese
lesbian and then but at least she got
her boots back they played them
oh god dude and now they're back to the
shoes it's beautiful and again again Fox
News The Producers over Tucker Carlson
show Tucker Carlson Nick Adams and even
some on the left don't realize you're
being played but here's the thing it's
not I bet this commercial well right
it's not just a lot of a lot of
Democrats I'm seeing big names on
Twitter fall for this and talking oh
they're they're they're full who are
they because I want to bring them up I
want to show yeah can you send me a link
of yeah yeah a couple examples of this
um because I I want to show this I want
to show that you people are getting
delayed for a Super Bowl commercial go
to the go to the post and go through the
comments and that's that'll be a good
song Oh the the Eminem post
oh okay yeah yeah yeah
um so the original and obviously if you
if you look for a quote tweet or
something I saw Keith olberson uh Keith
Olbermann yeah and I like Keith but yeah
yeah he went off and he was like oh they
folded to Tucker they no they didn't
Nick Adams Nick Adams bought this thing
he was like uh hey Adam Adam
uh because I got Adam barcamingo here
we've had Adam on the show I like Adam
but he's he says cowards no do they they
play they got you Palladium right they
got your plate this is parody this is
satire this is them playing the right so
it's not just so everyone yes everyone
knows the joke
Democrats or you know liberals leftists
whatever you want to call them also have
egg on their face right now yeah because
they took it literally uh but here's
here's another one and I don't mind
calling them out these are my friends
these are my friends I know these people
outspoken here says cowards you're
getting blade here yeah just go back and
read the statement look at that art like
Dave said they wouldn't put the
M M's the way they put them on there
right if they weren't because I I
because they is it confirmed that they
bought a goddamn commercial for the
Super Bowl is it confirmed yeah because
I I've there was a hold on let me make
sure I am almost positive yeah with
Eminem there's a a today show thing with
Eminem's spokesperson
on indefinite pause my Rudolph is
thrilled to be taken over following
controversy
uh
prefer to be in the commercial the brand
was looking for a spokesperson America
can agree on for a new Super Bowl ad
okay so it's you know I don't know how
long this was in development if this was
a recent like Hey we're gonna film a
Super Bowl commercial for next month
you're a new spokesperson but the idea
that they were like oh not only is she a
woman not only is she non-white
not only did she play vice
president Harris on SNL which definitely
has to pick oh that's really gonna piss
him off she's uh she's a left-leaming
comedian that's actually funny
can you imagine
if she shows up in the Super Bowl
commercial as Kamala Harris oh oh my God
and they they unveil some thing
with these characters because this is
all bait folks it's all bait for you to
watch what the happens in the
commercial and if they don't care in the
last two weeks right well again in the
last two weeks is when the outrage
really happened the following the last
week before that was really when all the
outrage happened
and last night funny enough I was
talking to my partner and I said uh
I was like man it really sucks I
wanted to make this what was that video
on M Ms I literally said this to her I
said I said last night as we're going to
bed I was like man I'm really out of
here that's all I talk about I go what
was that but I said to her and I said
what was that what would she well she's
probably like really yeah and that's
like she's like how long is is it gonna
take for you to read these jokes to me
so I go last night as we're going to bed
I said uh man really sucks because I had
all these good jokes written for this
Eminem stuff going at Nick Adams going
at Tucker Carlson going at uh you gotta
get on these I know like I know I know I
know we gotta pump these things
literally went to bed last night
thinking ah man all right well I guess
I'll just have to throw that one out and
then I wake up this morning to find out
did you find out when I sent it to you
yeah I found out oh my God because I
sent because I I my tweet was because I
I quote tweeted Eminem because and the
reason why is because I knew I I knew as
soon as I read it and looked at the
statement that they made that this is
trolling them and I said well the alpha
cut candies still have dicks for Nick
Adams question mark I wanted to make
sure I just want to make sure that any
changes they make that the candy is
still male in the package and it still
has wieners yeah for those because he
wants Eminem dick to melt in his mouth
not in his hand Nick yeah but he said
he's like no more M M's no no he didn't
say it that way how do you say it okay
he said I'm over Eminem's right not one
more Eminem will pass these lips until
until they're all male with all wieners
well he said until there is an all-male
package right right right and uh the
phrasing yeah uh I'm gonna I'm gonna to
give Eminem credit here yeah uh for the
should be but yeah so people people need
to understand that this is like I'm I'm
here here's Ben Collins Ben Collins is a
smart nude people Ben Collins is not
dumb I'm moving to a Shack in the forest
I'm no longer participating inside now
but he might be talking about how
Eminem's trolling them but I think he's
saying that Eminem cancel themselves or
some so yeah I really need to know
that this is all a big
this is all this is all a bit it's all a
bit in preparation for oh my God wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh my God one
hour ago breaking news hour ago
the alpha cuck Nick Adams yes
um he says we're gonna play this here I
haven't seen this we just know this no I
haven't seen it either okay so I thought
I honestly thought this was the other
one where he was talking about how
people should go to Hooters
he probably says the word Hooters in
this video for sure he says the word
Hooters in this video it isn't again he
tweets the Eminem suspended their spokes
candy as a result of my boycott
all right that's what they want you to
believe Debbie
um but men won't be satisfied until rep
oh my God
reparations are paid you scumbag
you scumbag this is the same guy
who oh my God yesterday he
had a tweet yesterday that said Michelle
Obama is horrible or awful it's
something some adjective
inside and out we also know that he was
like oh your kid should be less like
this and more like Kyle Rittenhouse and
it's like damn dude you really
putting out there it's racism huh hey
Nick I I know you're from Ozzy but ease
up on the reparations talk man
you might want to back away from that
especially since the new spokesperson is
um a POC you dumb I don't
know if he knows that yet well he did he
did read the statement because he posted
a quote well I assume he read the
statement because he quote
tweeted uh Nick Adams one Eminem zero
yeah yeah he took it he took it at face
value and again so did a lot of
Democrats right and we're going to come
out right now that this is all a bit
it's it's it's and they're
playing this idiot and they're actually
it's kind of sad though because man this
is what they do and this is how this is
how easy it is for Eminem and Mars to
bait these stupid into this
marketing ploy to bait them because I
think it's all for this ship Super Bowl
commercial oh they're baiting them all
for this commercial I mean whatever's
gonna happen where millions of people
are going to be watching God knows if
it's going to be the highest rated Super
Bowl ever it probably will be every year
it's the same thing it's the highest
rate who knows how many people
are going to watch this commercial and
they're just gonna have
their absolute brains
over this thing probably because what
also is a possibility is they might be
releasing multi because typically what
at what companies will do is they have
the big you know they'll have a bunch of
trailers and videos and stuff like this
and stuff that's coming out this year
because it's the most watched event in
uh in the year pretty much right you got
a lot of eyeballs that's why
they spend a lot of money a lot of money
if you know if you can if you can if you
can be an actor on a super black oh man
you just made bank for uh you're
gonna be in a lot of commercials
so the thing the thing that that people
need to understand here too is that um
is that is that companies also have
started doing like pre-commercial
teasers right there's the big commercial
and they might have multiple spots they
might have a 15 second spot a 30 second
spot and they're kind of telling a story
right they're telling they could be
telling a story they're like it might be
them like in the dressing room and she's
interacting because here's the thing she
might be if I had to predict Maya
Rudolph is going to be interacting with
a 3D uh spokes candy right and she might
even have to be like hey look I'm sorry
to give you the bad news and there might
be even this like Awkward Moment where
it's like oh oh sorry I'm here to play
this character and they're like I'm here
to play this character and they're like
Oh Maya we're ready for you to be on set
so there might be this whole like bit
where it's like she's replacing the
candy and they don't know about it so
it's super awkward we should totally cut
this and post this on the YouTube
channel because I feel like we're
predicting the future and it's gonna
happen and so they'll probably do little
vignettes of this story right of like
onset or other things or interactions
with the candy and they're gonna release
them also before not all of them but
they're gonna release maybe a couple and
they're gonna get
and slinging this around
Twitter right so Nick Adams goes on to
stay here in the tweet and we'll watch
the video because I'm sure it's I'm sure
it's full of self-parity and
self-satitis and he doesn't even realize
it
um with our Man cards intact he says
what the we will press on in our
boycott of Eminem's dude you're you're
rate their profits are going up because
of you but yeah sure we will not rest
until we have achieved complete and
total Victory well I don't know what the
that means I guess so he could have
the Eminem dicks in his mouth is that
what he means ladies let's listen to
this um
he's dead serious here look at this he
is in front of a picture of himself in
front of me he loves to show that photo
because I think that photo is him
introducing trumpets oh I see I see so
that's the alpha cuck photo where he's
cucking for for Trump Okay let's listen
to how serious he is about the Eminem
issue that our country is facing in the
crisis
that our country is facing with the
Eminem cancellation and again
they're they're claiming yay we canceled
them like they're cheering and yeah that
they canceled them it's so funny
that's all it is Boycott equals cancel
yeah I'm like let's listen ladies and
gentlemen Nick Adams here your favorite
Twitter account on the planet
oh my God
I can't but he's saying he's saying that
he okay so what he's saying is that he's
more popular on Twitter than I don't
know his cuck daddy Trump or his sip
Master Elon oh my I can't I can't even
tell you I
something makes me really believe that
that George Soros is paying this person
who is an actor who is pretending to be
this this has to be some kind of
conspiracy theory right I can't get over
it there's like
five percent of me right five percent of
my kind of like
feeling about this
is that he's actually Andy Kaufman and
he's gonna pull off the bodysuit
and be like hey guys and then be like
it's really me
oh my God like I you know we we
are really lacking on the Sorrows chicks
you know they talk about them but let me
tell you something let me tell you
something in the in the imaginary minds
of Q Anon how great would it be
if this guy was paid directly from
George Soros you can make a
movie about this maybe I shouldn't say
this out loud we're giving away
ideas here but George Soros pulls him in
personally talks to this guy he's not
Australian he's probably gonna a
completely different accent he's got to
go learn at it have the accent and then
he's paying him to do all this because
it really is just just satire
and parody of themselves everything he
does I can't even believe that this is
real but let's listen to this
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life now I'm sure that you've heard the
fantastic news which is that Eminem's
and Mars are taking an indefinite pause
on their spokes candies and that ladies
and gentlemen you can attribute directly
to me
um let me down let me download this
video before he takes it down
well because here's the other thing too
is he's taking credit for it and really
you know he claims he's got this big
platform which I mean a lot of people
listen to him it's mainly people who
want to laugh at him like us but
to to assume that the reason why Eminem
candy is doing this is because of this
guy he's they're doing it because of
Tucker Carlson you sniveling
little Tucker Carlson speaks to
gazillions more dumb than you do
that will buy this Eminem hat doesn't
have and and getting rid of woke cartoon
character Tucker Carlson is way
more advanced than you'll ever be Nick
Adams
um you're just literally doing parody of
yourself but let's let's continue with
the greatest
Andy Kaufman type of his time
you are welcome we took a strong stand
and we got this as a result is that what
he says is that what he says if somebody
says after
after he he which ah never mind he's
probably never been to the woman he's
probably never been no are you kidding
me listen also so he lives in Texas
right okay um he uh so is that where
this is at this is at his house yeah
yeah yeah and it was uh
uh who gave it to this Scott Perry
no it was trying to remember anyway uh
he lives in Texas he has his house
because it's you know cheap down
there he has this house and whenever he
makes his videos
he if I had to imagine the layout of
this house you walk in there's stairs on
the left which I've seen right and I
feel like this is
as soon as you walk in she's looking at
four years there's probably yeah there's
like Fourier area where it's like
probably 15 feet ahead of you or how did
you say it for for how'd you say it
what Fourier Fourier yeah is that what
you said what do you say they say
foreign you said for you I say foyer
because I say salsa too I just you know
I want to sniff this out this is
important stuff
how do you say it I say foyer because
I'm a hillbilly okay let's see
if I go to say Fourier
fancy
no it's it's foyer it's foyer see four
years I don't know why I put it sorry
fragile it's French Foreign
there's Fourier uh Fargo uh in this
foyer I would have to imagine that this
thing is the for like when you open the
doors and walk in right 15 feet or so in
front I would imagine that is where he
is right now
be sure to show the light that you're
seeing to his side is the light through
the front door
no no no no I think it's probably
through some window or something I don't
know I think it's an open area that has
windows with light coming in I see but
if I had to imagine this guy also
doesn't have Furniture in his
house well the other thing his shirt's
not on straight look at this this
guy's shirt's not on straight he says
he's the most favorite Twitter account
in the world he he rushed to make this
video no dude look he doesn't even have
pants on he was like he was in the
bathroom jerking it'd be like oh
my God and then ran down the stairs
slipped fell and then was like okay
let's make this video huh and again he's
by himself he puts up a tripod by
himself and he goes
okay mate all right let's let's let's
finish let's see if he has bands on in
this video let's let's see if we can
sniff that out but for anybody that is
under the illusion that somehow this
ends our boycott or that this egregious
sexism I want to point out there's no
way he's got pants on because his shirt
is untucked did you notice that his his
suit jacket is the same length as
Trump's he he's got the shirt untucked
because he's covering you know
yeah he ain't even got pants on but look
at this look at the collar here it's all
up he can't even get his shirt on
straight while he got his jacket I
didn't look in the mirror before he
started this thing yeah isn't displayed
by Mars and Eminem's can just be quickly
brushed under the carpet that's got
another thing coming oh my God
this boycott will not end until
reparations uh oh my god
listen Gabe Sanchez if you were gonna
write a commercial a fake ass commercial
for this show you couldn't write one as
good as this about this Eminem they're
no way could you write one as
good as this it just oh my God it's so
it's so hilarious thing he
thinks he's yeah serious I don't know if
the reparations dig
or mention is a dig at Maya Rudolph like
I don't know if he's that smart or if he
made it intentionally for her right well
he's he's definitely digging on the
whole BLM woke thing right totally he's
definitely digging on that
um because he's dead he's he's playing
the deadpan on this he's not you know
he's not doing like he did when he went
and smashed the M M's or he's like it's
so funny so funny huh he really he might
believe that he has caused Eminem to
make this statement what a bonehead and
these are our demons number one
in some countries when you count on your
hands it's one two one three four five
or even if you go one but when you have
two up like that's two not one two not
one well yeah have you ever seen two it
feels like he's it feels like he's
making a terrorist video for demands of
a hostage right he's like our demands
our demands like what have you ever seen
uh uh was it Bedazzled
yeah yeah have you ever seen the movie
bedazzled with Brendan Fraser
uh probably all right so in this movie
he makes a deal with the devil right and
he's given these wishes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah what's her name plays in it
the British actress who is yes uh no
Austin Powers I forget her name
uh Hurley Elizabeth Hurley yeah yeah
yeah so
so uh
this is there's a moment when he was
like oh I want to be like super
successful because she's the devil in
the movie yeah she's the devil and she
makes a deal with them and they go
through all these scenarios where he
plays different characters and in one of
them I think she says uh okay what do
you want to do or what do you want to be
and he goes I want to be famous I want
like I want to be rich and famous and
everyone like loves me
and he gets to he gets to become or in
athletic I think because each time he's
like changing yeah I think the famous
one he drove a Lambo or something well
the so one of them he becomes a
basketball player right and in the video
he goes to ESPN on the camera is like
Diablos are number one and puts up a two
because in exchange for being rich and
famous he's also idiot and he
has a small dick kind of like Nick Adams
anyway oh my God so not you're not
pointing out that there's no correlation
there as well yeah no not at all not at
all between that imaginary character and
this imagine yeah I mean if I had to
give you one reason
it's that Nick Adams is a Cup oh
here we go packet of Eminem's two we
want an apology directed specifically to
me until that time oh my God not one m m
will pass our lips
you got to be me that this
guy okay
he is he is so concerned and so
but yum yum yum in my tom tom this is
beautiful I'm a man are you a man I'm a
man and I don't give a I don't give
a how you draw the cartoon
characters on a pack of M M's I don't
care if you put the cartoon characters I
don't give what you do I'm gonna
eat them bastards yeah
and these will pass these Lids right
right because they're good and
it's candy it's not why the how in
the did we get here where these
people think this about gender they're
always like oh the left makes everything
about gender and everything about
genitalia like you people are freaking
out over cartoon characters on a goddamn
candy package you're freaking out about
it and
the the idea behind this woke leftist
antifa candy
is that Eminem's was like hey we want to
we want to support women's rights in
inclusivity So when you buy this candy
we're going to be donating portions of
this to this organization and this fund
but Republican it makes me want to eat
it even more right candy that's
anti-fascist it is that much sweeter
when it hits those lips just amazing
candy that hates Hitler I'm all for it
like what oh my god let's
we got a few more we got about 28
seconds left of this this vile sludge
let's see if we can work our way through
it he definitely doesn't have pants on
though no way to see it no not
at all we definitely got to go through
this and see if you can catch like a
thigh or something like the color of his
thigh or something it's got to be in
there somewhere
we are
us we are determined
the ingredients
of feminism of Mars and M Ms have no
place in modern America you don't have
pants
until then we'll probably just stay with
skills
foreign
last was the last week it was Twix which
he didn't know that Mars also makes well
they make right Twigs or left right they
don't make the right yeah it's a fascist
it's a fascist company that makes the
right Twigs yeah and not the leftist
right because you can't have a left-wing
uh woke group like Mars making the right
Twix no not at all they only yeah what
the hell did you just send me so this is
a I'm I was well first off I was told
that I should be looking for some
breaking news in uh my DMs but also it's
an updated video of George Santos doing
drag in Brazil oh oh okay so so I wonder
if Nick Adams
because I know he's super
concerned about what how the M M's are
dressed and what gender they are is Nick
Adams and Tucker Carlson gonna be
outraged and obsessed with George Santos
and rather he is or isn't a drag
performer or if it's just the thing that
he did when he was young do you think
they're going to be obsessed I don't
know yeah I don't know probably not
probably not because it's all
it's all fake Eminem knows that
that's why they're playing you here's a
video that you just sent me from Patriot
takes of um what looks like George
Santos and Drake what's what's his um
what's his drag queen name again uh
Katara ravage oh yeah is the way so and
I could be I could be butchering that I
was trying to find the right way to say
it but I believe how I've seen it
because it's Eula Richard is the one
that came out and was like actually
George Santos did drag with me I was
kind of his mentor that's that's the
other uh that's the other job in Brazil
yeah the 58 year old performer yudel
Richard famous in Brazil and his
community
and he's actually 54 that's actually his
name
he's not a santorian candidate yeah not
a santorian candidate not a scam train
candidate not a not not George scantos
so I just want to make sure updated
video of other footage because here's
the thing George Santa was like no no no
this is categorically false and it is
outrageous I've never done drag never
never never done in my life and then the
drag community in Brazil was like all
right bet and so then they went through
because before this happened before he
said that Eula Richard had shared photos
newspaper clippings uh other photos have
been like here he here's George Santos
as this here's Joe Santos is this here's
us together here's this and then
afterward he was like this is
categorically false this is not me blah
blah blah
so yeah so then the drag Community was
like here's the footage you all want the
T here it is well so I want to tell you
before I play this I'm almost sure I'm
not gonna be offended by this video I'm
almost positive just like I'm not
offended by Eminem's
uh cartoons I can't but I can't tell you
this is before or after
George Santos went to story time oh okay
well that's possible because I I'm
really I'm probably not going to be
offended by this
um it's going to be hilarious to
watch him try to react and Republicans
not react this because I'm sure there's
going to be no outrage over this all
outrage is going to be directed towards
Eminem and Mars let's let's watch
video image
this is like a professional production
this isn't like a cell phone video no no
yeah this is from okay from whatever
this Festival was a performance this is
you know this is this is him here in the
red yep yep yep or her I mean I guess
he's playing the character there yeah
he's he's performing this is guitar that
in the red right okay yeah and then is
this the person next to him is that the
one uh the one that you're talking about
that's not no that's that's not okay
okay I just want to make sure Eula
Richard is is lighter skinned okay okay
yeah
um so that's the footage that's being
released um buying Patriot takes I'm
guessing it was from some sort of news
yeah
this is you just happen to be in the
shot I don't I mean look there's a
there's an unspoken rule in life do not
betray a drag queen and that's like a
Dragon Here on YouTube says the dress he
is wearing RuPaul wouldn't be caught
dead in yeah I mean you know Sashay away
baby Sashay away you know again I I
honestly watched that video and I didn't
see anything offensive in it no I don't
there's nothing offensive in it people
were doing what they felt comfortable
doing and they were out celebrating at a
festival why not no one should here
let's let's just clear the air here
no one should be uh
you know no pun intended or pun intended
I guess nobody should be dragging George
Santos for wearing drag right that's not
the problem right you shouldn't be
attacking the drag Community let's just
put that out there right you want to do
that that's great that's wonderful you
want to be who you are celebrate
those things has Matt all said anything
about this because I think that's what
you're going to say against the parties
yeah the offensive man Walsh said
anything about George Santos I haven't
seen any well I haven't looked yet but I
can look right now but but the big
problem is the hypocrisy and it's not
really George Santos's right hypocrisy
well it I mean it is I mean it is
yeah but I mean come on right it's not
surprising that this guy is going to go
through this cycle over and over and
over again right he's just a dumb
right yeah and and he's a person who who
wants to be a republican so they have to
lie it's in their DNA and that's just
what's gonna happen so really he's
um the the you know he's just the the
side show and all this yeah the real
problem here is that there's real
people's lives at danger because they're
stoking fear on this but they won't
Stoke any fear towards a republican
congressperson who voted for Kevin
McCarthy and who's now best friends with
Matt gatz and Marjorie Taylor green
right and I'm sure they're not going to
say a goddamn thing about George Santos
being a drag performer which um there's
a video out there Gabe Sanchez
of um George Santos walking through an
airport and he's asked again if he was a
drag performer and he says no but and he
does have a huge butt in there I'm
talking about what he was doing in
Brazil if I can quickly find that is the
exact because it's it's hard to hear
um here I'll just upload it because I
have it downloaded oh the uh this video
of yeah yeah I'll get it for you if you
can't find it then I'll get it
and I thought I had it but I
I do not
um I I didn't retweet it I I liked it on
a few platforms and people were posting
okay
but then then when we got 15 damn we
only got 15 minutes like this two hours
went by fast and that Eminem um
that 45 minute commercial for M M's
you owe me you owe me sponsorship
Eminem's
sons of
here we go this is so this is the clip
you ready it's only 30 seconds long it's
uh George Santos being uh stopped by or
confronted by TMZ in the airport
um and asked about his uh his past
drag is that the top okay I'll play it
um
uh look guys I wish you guys well I'm
gonna go in an elevator and I'm gonna go
to my car and I'm gonna go home
I was young and I had fun at a festival
he was young and he had fun at a
festival yeah sure absolutely I think I
think I think drab performances look
really fun I mean that video that he was
in it looked like he was having fun of
me dressed up and for anyone who's
curious what he said was uh no I was not
a drag queen no I was not a drag queen
in Brazil guys I was just or I was young
and just I had fun at a festival yep so
if you want to do that that's whatever
but you know do not be associated with
and this is the problem that this is the
big problem here right it's not that he
did drag or was it drag queen it's the
hypocrisy of saying no I never did it
and also being a part of a group that
Villa villainizes people who do do that
right
there are bills being proposed across
the country you've got people you know
Ron DeSantis in Florida you've got all
these other people like Margaret Taylor
green Lauren bobert like all of these
people who are trying to go against the
lgbtq community as well as those who are
doing drag and make them the villains
when they're not right they're trying to
take away their rights they're trying to
wait take away things that would be uh
that they could do they're trying to say
it's illegal for you to show up to this
venue it's illegal for you to do this
story time it's illegal for this or for
that or whatever
and that's Republicans shut off
closed-minded bigoted don't like other
people that are not like them and they
don't like the idea that someone else
feels comfortable to do their own thing
in their own body that makes them happy
and that is why Republicans are so
outraged at people who do do Greg and
George Sanchez being a part of it is a
problem let me let me give you another
example of this that they're doing in
Iowa we we heard uh last week that
Missouri is trying to make women not
expose their arms and the legislator
floor in the election oh is this the
uniform outfit yeah they're
they're scared they're gonna get horny
or something all right women showing
their arms I don't know what these guys
I don't know
how the are you supposed to I mean
it reminds me of um
I'm blanking on it right now but the
idea that they're like oh you can't show
any skin they're like oh that's I mean
it's religious that makes that makes me
get the feel feels and I hornies rapey
Vibes and yeah and because you're
dressed that way I'm a scuzz bag and you
I can't keep my wiener in my pants
speaking of that I guess Tim Allen
whipped out his dick uh in front of
Pamela Anderson I'm just gonna lay that
there okay so Rachel I'm just saying
it's a story I don't know if
it's true I don't know she's saying I'm
sure it's true she said it I believe her
I don't believe him don't I mean he's a
trump supporter this is yeah you know
these are things that you have to pay
for when you do things I mean you just
assume look if if you hear a story
assume that it's probably uh well one
assuming it's true two assume that it
could be worse probably worse I'm sure
it is but I'm just gonna lay that there
Rachel made a copper tweets about
another state that's north of Missouri
Iowa and the what the Republicans are
doing up there it seems kind of funny
after spending years roasting Michelle
Obama's school lunch initiative Iowa
Republicans propose limiting the types
of foods that can be purchased on snap
um of course these are the proposed
restrictions no white grains no baked
refried Jesus people uh purchase black
red and Pinto they can they can't get
refried baked beans and chili beans but
they can get black red pinto beans
basically there's no ways they don't
want anything fresh see well uh no fresh
meats all Frozen right that's what they
want no sliced cubed or crumbled cheese
no no American what I thought this was
America first Gabe Sanchez no American
cheese are you kidding me what
kind of Tommy bastards are these Iowa
Republicans uh what's next house
subcommittee will consider the bill so
what they want to do is restrict the
diet of snap I don't know if people know
what snap is it's it's welfare
it's food stamps it's what they're
always demonizing people having now
unbeknownst to Republicans in
this country they don't know that the
majority of people who receive snap in
this country as far as demographic is
white people white people receive more
stamp more snap more food stamps because
they live in conservative areas they're
rural areas they're broke they're poor
they don't have access to decent
fresh food and one way that they only
have access to it is through Snap
through Snap because Republican
politicians are scuzz bags now
why what does this have to do with Mel
Michelle Obama's initiative Michelle
Obama's initiative if you go back and
you remember
um she was promoting that children in
schools could eat as many vegetables as
they possibly could eat the school had
to provide them with as many vegetables
as they could possibly eat but they had
to make sure that they were getting
macronutrients in a certain percentage
to these children right if anyone does
any kind of health studies macros are
important part of diet and or anyone who
does like you know body lifting training
like you know yeah you're gonna build
muscle or be healthy or you got to
watch the macros right right I
mean you got to get it down to the
the ounce of that wait you mean
you got to get it down to uh science oh
good oh man so Rachel bittick offer here
pointing out the hypocrisy because yeah
and in the other way they're trying to
get rid of they're they're they're
they're they're going woke in Iowa
they're going woke on on food stamps and
I I honestly gave senses what they're
trying to do is restrict
um people like this idea that no baked
refried or chili beans God damn me and
you both know what culture yeah each
baked refried chili beans for crying out
loud I mean it's not rocket
science what they're trying to do here
and and if anyone doesn't know Iowa's a
huge farming State and there is
a lot a lot of migrants that go to Iowa
to work on farms a ton there's a
ton of poultry farms in Iowa a
ton of poultry farms and what people
don't know about poultry and what they
don't know about meat packing
plants is it's mostly migrant workers
who work there because it is the
shittiest nastiest grossest hardest work
that you will ever have and you will
never find an entitled white
American working those jobs because
they're too good for them but they won't
don't want migrants to have them you
pieces of and that is
exactly who they're targeting here is
the is the migrant communities
with this no baked refried or chili
beans come on man yeah come on give me a
break and and no fresh meat no fresh
meat you're not you're telling me you're
gonna you're you're not targeting
marginalized communities with no fresh
meat come on give me a break anyone who
knows anything about about any
communities in rural Iowa knows that
targeting people with no fresh meat from
the grocery store is targeting
marginalized and poor people and again I
mean it's snap programs but they're
children folks
children these are kids they're
always like oh save the kids protect the
kids we need to we need to protect the
kids from people reading them stories
but don't feed those
decent nutrition their nutrition
the hell with that we just don't want
people to teach them how to read and and
not only that we're not going to give
them the energy to know how to read so
yeah thanks and point that out and the
idea that because it's not just um
it's not just that it's giving these
kids nutrition it's the fact that these
kids might not be able to get those
resources
and those nutrients and you know and
those meals outside of school so the one
Safe Haven to be like look
if we can at least give this kid
something of sust of like sustenance and
value for their diet as they grow up
because again these are developing kids
there was never a more important time
to make sure you get the proper rest uh
activity food nutrients diet whatever
then when you're a kid right to help
with development of your body your brain
your mind as you learn
but they don't want to do that even for
the kids that might be well especially
for the kids that are that might not
have X access to those resources in
their home so they're like Michelle
Obama's like look if there's one place
we can guarantee a kid will eat and get
a meal that day we're going to make sure
that he gets or she gets the proper meal
in their diet
if we can control anything outside of
fostering a developing community of of
Young Learners let's at least give them
a meal that can help them
along the way
yeah that would that would be helping
out Children right these are these are
not fetuses Gabe Sanchez these are
actually living breathing humans and
they don't like living breathing humans
especially the pores okay they don't
like the pores okay I mean they want the
pores to be born but they don't like the
poorest
um speaking of people who are morons and
this account here I pointed out before
um is uh posting stupid videos
online trying to tie it to covid and
over the last several days they've been
posting videos of people faking seizures
um this one here and I'm gonna show you
it and I'm gonna mock them and that's
and this is the Dismount for the day I'm
trying to decide if it was this or the
Trump at Diamond's funeral and I'm going
with this because from we'll talk
about that one tomorrow sure well we
yeah but like there's not going to be
any more of these scuzz bags bringing up
videos and we're not gonna have plenty
of to go through but yeah we might
get to the him talking about himself uh
during Diamond's eulogy now this is an
exorcism oh my God this is so stupid so
they post that all this is false I want
to have a disclaimer this is all
this is fake this isn't
real net nor is this account who God
knows who the hell this account is I
wish I could find out exactly who this
is so we could expose them it probably
has to do with lives a tick tock to be
quite honest with you they're probably
somehow uh Affiliated but it says urgent
Angelina 45 a health care worker was
mandated to take Pfizer's covid vaccine
which is not true uh uh healthcare
workers had a choice you either you keep
your job you get vaccinated or you don't
keep your job it's your choice that's a
choice not a not you're not forced now
three days later paralyzed from the legs
down followed by severe convulsions and
seizures seizures uh can no longer clean
cook drive a car requires full-time
caretaker quote I'm a prisoner in my own
home normally Gabe Sanchez when someone
becomes paralyzed they say I'm a
prisoner in my own body yeah they're
home but you know who am I to say
um I want to show you this video of her
and and I want to point out I'm not
going to turn the audio off because I
want to point something out but watch
this video it's real quick and then I'll
show you my take on it
what's going on this home down
just fit me over there's no sense of
holding me it doesn't help
oh this is so big okay I gotta stop it
there I'm gonna tell you I'm just gonna
say one thing yeah I'm gonna tell you as
someone who I had a friend in high
school and she suffered from epilepsy so
she did she had her seizures she had
seizures she actually had a an implant
uh done in her inner inner skull that
helped to regulate to make sure yeah are
you telling me that seizures are a
neurological condition because this this
lady who is a nurse supposedly yeah does
not know that it's a neurological
doesn't help if you hold me Shut the
up lady listen when someone's
having a seizure they normally are not
even audible because it's a neurological
thing you can't yeah you can't you can't
control your the nervous system yeah to
move your muscles yeah yeah let alone
you talk move yeah the talking aspect
when you have a seizure you have no no
control over anything also the
controlled seizure that she has bent
legs no that is not that is not what
would happen the other thing is
um in high school I also who and and my
friend's doctor uh was a
neurosurgeon like a someone who deals on
brains worked on brains the girl that I
dated in high school her father was the
top neurological like specialist surgeon
in the well in the world he actually got
sent out to go work on Ted Kennedy when
he was having issues
um and do a consultation
and work with him in terms of what they
could do but this is as someone and
again you know I'm just giving you faker
than the Nick Adams video just giving
you Anna and here I'll just preface this
I'm just giving you anecdotal data here
from two people I know and someone who
is a professional now I could you know
you might say oh it's the same as
somebody who says they are like this
woman who's having a seizure but
I'll just say this uh she's not having a
seizure that's not how seizures are and
the fact that she would have control
over her arms and her legs to keep them
in that position as well as talk not a
thing not a thing I do have to admit
though I gotta admit
this lady's Shake Weight her Shake
Weight form is of perfection I mean
these are actual people in an audience
doing
here at first I was like wait did
somebody just like splice these into all
these people no that's a lot of no
that's that they're she's got perfect
Shake wake form I mean look at this look
look at the shake weight form she's got
here compare this
to this I've never seen anyone or heard
of anyone being able to communicate with
their words while having a seizure now I
get that there could be a wide range
right you could have a slight seizure
and a very a grand seizure right but the
if the fact that she's able to control
certain aspects to get out a certain
message to the video no
I I and I'm totally mocking her this is
what I'm doing right now is mocking her
just like I'm going to uh um I said I
was going to Dismount with this but one
other story before we leave while we're
talking about this covet hoax
um there was a lady
um who um she's she's a conservative
person and
um she looks crazy yeah so Canon this
person here on Facebook that her
employer granted her religious exemption
for the coveted vaccine here's the the
quote she dies they're quote hang on
here's the quote from her Facebook page
no jabby jabby for me
praise God she wrote on Facebook in
November and is dead she's dead a
conservative activist
oh I need some oh wow
we should if we can if we could overlay
audio on this but there is a video of a
guy playing a trombone on YouTube where
he's like
oh she died she died because
had a religious exemption from the
coveted vaccine
for her Gabe praise the Lord praise the
Lord now she's gonna meet her savior
yeah what do you think he's gonna say
they're like hold on hold on you think
he's gonna be a you think
she's gonna meet guys
She's Gotta Go the Pearly Gates
vaccine that um we helped create as uh
the creators of Earth and all the things
in it we see that you rejected that so
straight to hell to you oh my God it's
also like when somebody's like oh I
don't need the I don't need the vaccine
I don't need the jab God's Gonna Save Me
Right look there's a lot of events that
have happened in the world and a lot of
diseases that have happened and a lot of
people die from these diseases because
whether there's a vaccine or not a
vaccine but if God really was a savior
and he really was going to come out here
and be like hey you're my people you're
my children I want to make sure that
you're okay all those people would have
never died and the fact that you're now
dumb and looking at this and be like
God's Gonna Save Me God's like
I I I all I gave you the thing
to save yourself you know what you know
what's funny is um that these people
don't realize about their God is that if
there is one they that God which there
is a God it should be a woman but it
clearly if it is a man if there is one
because he everything up but
here's the thing is that if God is real
God invented natural selection so thank
you for being a worshiper of natural
selection uh everybody thanks for
joining us here on the Tony Michaels
podcast as you do two hours every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central on YouTube Twitter
and and and twitch yeah there you go
yeah there we go and uh also Simon
casting on the Midas touch Facebook page
don't forget to follow us on YouTube if
you're there now or if you're on another
platform come over to the Tony Michaels
podcast subscribe there we're trying to
get to 20 000 also follow us on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod download every
single episode follow us on Facebook
Anthony Tony Michaels if you're on
Facebook and hell why not that one I
couldn't remember twitch go get the app
it's free first moment I thought you
were having a seizure from your jab I
was twitching from the Twitchy twitch
thing jab that I was having okay
um everybody don't get the shakes don't
get the Shivers
um be here tomorrow same time same place
Surfside you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon